you hear that grilling mangoes are the
sound of summer
ooh baby
[Music]
hey i'm she here recipe developer here
at tasty and it's summertime which means
it's perfect for grilled steak tacos and
a mango salsa and i'm going for the
highest quality
aaa steak and freshest produce so i'm
ordering from walmart now
it's as easy as this orders in groceries
are going to be here in no time then we
start cooking
all right groceries have arrived let's
see what we got
oh yeah so we've got the triple a
angus strip one the star of the show
when it comes to a steak taco and
produce
red peppers red onion we're gonna grill
fresh ripe
avocados i think we've got everything we
need i'm going to get organized and then
we're going to start the first step
marinating the steak
all right let's start with our marinade
so i've got some beautiful dry spices a
little bit of oregano
into the bowl paprika to give us that
color a little bit of smokiness
cinnamon and a lot of people don't use
cinnamon when it comes to beef but it's
awesome a little bit of garlic powder
and onion powder of course
and we'll whisk all that together we go
in with a little bit of fresh garlic
some olive oil loosen that all up
and this is one of my favorite
ingredients especially for a grilled
taco
adobo so this is the kind of tomato
sauce that chipotles are packed in
and last thing before we add the steaks
i want the lime
zest and of course the juice and then
let's talk our steaks
so i've got a couple beautiful looking
aaa strip loins and they
are exactly what i want beautiful color
even marbling and not too too fatty
which is perfect i'm gonna throw these
into our marinade
and they're gonna soak up all that
flavor take on that color
now these should marinate for at least
two hours but you can even do it
overnight day before you start to grill
while our steaks are marinating this is
a perfect opportunity to grill our mango
salsa
a nice medium heat pan here and i just
want to put them on the grill for a
couple minutes
to get those natural sugars caramelized
you hear that grilling mangoes are the
sound of summer
ooh baby and now we're gonna go on with
the red peppers and the onions i'm gonna
put a little bit of salt and pepper as
well
just to kind of get them started and
where the mango's only grilled for a
couple minutes
just to char i'm gonna cook these for
about six to seven minutes so that they
really cook through and soften
it's smelling good looking good let's
take a flip and take a look what we've
got
oh yeah that's the color you want that
deep char i like it that color
i'm gonna let these chill for a minute
or two then we'll chop it up into our
salsa
our mangoes and veg look perfect let's
turn it into a salsa so just like
earlier i'm gonna use the zest of a lime
a little bit of fresh squeezed lime
juice olive oil
some fresh cilantro and i know not
everyone loves cilantro if
you are against cilantro a little bit of
parsley would be great and now is the
time to season
with another pinch of salt wake up those
flavors
okay this looks great i'm gonna set this
aside and then we'll move on to the
steaks
i've got my grill pan smoking hot it's
time to grill these steaks so these have
marinated for a couple hours i brought
them to room temperature
now is the time you want to season with
salt and pepper not beforehand
and you can see that my grill is really
hot this is going to allow me to sear
really high ah
for a minute or two then i'll knock down
the heat so that we can finish cooking
them
i love that smell when the marinade hits
the grill right away it smells amazing
and it actually complements the high
quality beef
now when searing steak don't touch it
don't peek at it don't move it
let it sear let the mayard reaction as
we call it
caramelize okay let's give these bad
boys a flip
oh yeah i like that deep char
it's a deep char i love it so now that
i've got that beautiful color on the top
i'm gonna knock it down to a medium heat
and continue cooking it
through to a medium i wish you could
smell this if you want to know how this
smells you got to try it you got to make
this recipe at home
okay guys look at this spread looks
unbelievable it's finally time to
assemble our tacos before i do that i'm
just going to grab
a fresh and ripe avocado give it a pinch
of salt
and i actually like to combine my
avocado with the sour cream
to kind of make it like an avocado crema
of sorts
just spread it around some finely sliced
lettuce
a little bit of cheddar cheese of course
we'll get our
steak that we've cubed up so it's
perfect to layer onto our taco a little
bit of that
vibrant mango salsa right on top
look at that and last but not least i
need a little bit of hot sauce
the steak is spicy but not too spicy you
get the chipotle you get the spices from
the marinade
and then you get the tang from the salsa
the sweetness
the char of the veggies this is the taco
of the summer
that's good if you gave this recipe a
try leave a comment down below and if
you haven't
what are you waiting for it's summer
it's time to hit the grill
oh yes